it's not just one shade of black and
white
right so nowadays there are many amazing
amazing women entrepreneurs
in the specific group that i grew up in
uh
in my family there were no women who
worked outside of the home except for
one ant
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford this one is all about passion
and the entrepreneurial journey
meet redwater kleinhandler ceo and
founder of rooms and words
jarva is the ceo of rooms and words a
marketing and strategy consulting agency
and a future of work expert previously
jedwa was the co-founder and ceo of
emerge
an award-winning startup which brought
micro mentoring to fortune 500 companies
like facebook
siemens and more she is passionate about
the future of learning diversity and
career growth
and has given keynote speeches on those
subjects and more at facebook microsoft
all cloud and other leading companies
as well as ngos gerva's work has been
featured on huffington post
wired the bbc and more fedva
kleinhandler thank you for joining me on
20 minute leaders all the way from
nebrake how are you
i am so good and very grateful for you
pronouncing my name correctly that
doesn't happen often
well what the viewers don't know is that
we've been practicing right before
starting this recording so it's a
but i'll take the compliment so thank
you for that but
you know i said my first sentence uh
which i now i i undercut myself i said
all the way from black it's not really
all the way it really is about
five streets uh east of where i am i
believe
so but but there is a there is a
mentality of all the way and
you're not the typical you know a
television
you know entrepreneur that grows up to
be to be a businesswoman and so
while there are a lot of really
interesting things that we're going to
be talking about i'd love to start from
your background a little bit
and and understand how how you grew to
become a businesswoman
how you grew to to have you know over i
think like i counted three dozen
different
companies that you've been involved with
in a really meaningful way
how does that happen how do you grow up
to be such a remarkable you know
entrepreneurial spirit of course you
just become religious and you move to
benebrach and then it's
just all strawberries from there right
so no i
i completely agree i think it feels like
there's such a distance even though our
entire country is
i think smaller or just the same size of
new jersey
it feels like there's a chasm between uh
different groups and different locations
and in fact yesterday was international
women's day and i spoke
um at a unicef and you uh
stack um uh in india
uh to women about entrepreneurship and i
you know what i felt like there was less
of a distance
uh between those women and where i come
from in many ways
um so i i do want to say that even in
the ultra orthodox community in nebraska
where i come from
it's not just one shade of black and
white right
so nowadays there are many amazing
amazing women entrepreneurs
in the specific group that i grew up in
uh
in my family there were no women who
worked outside of the home except for
one aunt
let alone entrepreneurs but i do think
that
even with women entrepreneurs in the
community today
technology feels very unaccessible
and very different and that's not
right it's not surprising even in
technology in general and secular and in
general
um population we're dealing with uh with
that
does it seem accessible does it seem
like a good fit does it seem like
something that's
relevant uh for girls and in the future
women
um for me specifically i never saw
myself
as an entrepreneur or as someone who's
who loves technology i honestly thought
i would be a writer and an author
when i grew up yeah i still love writing
uh kind of an obsessive writer on social
media
you can you can check it out um but i
did grow up feeling two very very
different things
so one was i was made to feel my family
like i'm talented and like i can do
whatever i want
and the other one was a lot of fear fear
of risk and like you know
michael uh startups and tech in general
are all about risk so i think that was
a big uh chasm the most
the most uh meaningful chasm to really
cross
um and then i started so i started for
something that was very close to what i
wanted
i became a translator and i just
i just started writing about things that
i cared about like interior design like
books i'm a huge bookworm i have
lots and lots of books at home um i was
gonna say you have over two thousand
books in your house right
i do and over 500 of them belong to my
son
which i'm very proud of uh so yeah wow
okay yeah and i think for me it started
from just really doing things i cared
about
so writing about design for example when
we were moving
homes and i wanted to find inspiration
not as an expert not as an interior
designer just gathering
my inspiration it was before instagram
and pinterest
and kind of doing i think this is
something that a lot of entrepreneurs
talk about
doing work like working at your hobbies
so when you care about something really
sitting
every day and writing like sometimes
even three blog posts a day
just because you're obsessive to it um
and that led me to
that led me to so many of the things
that i've done
from writing in magazines about design
to being contacted by houzz as one of
their first freelancers
i didn't even know back then it was in
that it was started by two israeli
entrepreneurs in the silicon valley
so right it's not about nobody
yeah nobody discovered me but by doing
the work
and by really being obsessive and by
um kind of investing your time and your
passion
i feel like you discover so many things
right and and even before we we go into
that and see how that's being translated
then to you starting off the different
initiatives and your entrepreneurial
journey
to your you're the ceo of rooms and word
and words and
before that you had an interesting
startup emerge that had an interesting
turn of events
that we'll talk about soon but but i
have to go back all the way to you being
a security guard and a cashier at your
own family's orchard as your first
job and uh you know i i love hearing
about people's first
jobs you know whether it's lemonade
stands or security guard and cashier for
the family orchard
what was that like and what did you
learn you know hands on
through through that first pay job
so that was a really interesting summer
uh my family had many
many orchards many citrus orchards in
israel
for actually over a hundred years a
hundred and eleven years
uh and it's the citrus that's called
atol game we use
them in sukkot part of their jewish
ritual um
and so every summer they had like a huge
um storage place where they would pack
all this citrus fruit
and send them to america to brazil
all over the world and they needed a
cashier and
of course like if i'm already the
cashier why not put my desk
right the front and kind of also act as
a security guard
and that was the same summer that where
i did my sats
so i would study it as a an s.a.t course
all day until the afternoon and i would
come to the orchard
and will do that until like one or two
or three a.m because those were the
crazy hours that's a good training for
entrepreneur
by the way so all crazy hours of the
night and i still remember
the amazing amazing coffee uh that we
would drink there
and i think i think you know i grew up
as you said in a very different setting
and environment and with different
expectations
but seeing my dad and my grandfather
wake up at 5am go and check
the orchards because citrus are very
very sensitive fruit
and then go and work at real estate and
also go to the synagogue and pray three
times a day so
i really saw them investing in what they
loved
and it was never about complaining it
was always such a passion of course they
were tired of course they were sometimes
burnt out of course as a kid i would
like
miss my dad and write him letters but
it was just so fulfilling and you could
you could feel it in the air
so i think one thing is really really
feeling that
in all your senses it's very sensory
experience
and the other thing is really
understanding that when you care about
something you do
everything when i was a ceo for many
years i
also sweep to the floors right i didn't
say oh it's beneath me or something like
that
so and i think every every founder and
ceo can relate to that so i think that
was a really great lesson for me
so a perfect segue the role of a ceo you
know
just uh hearing about your journey first
the passion
the passion that you're exuding comes
across
the the webcam you know perfectly i'm
hearing you talk about
you know all the way from being a
cashier and security guard with orchards
all the way to writing content to
reading books to now being the ceo
i think that what you're exemplifying
here truly is just this entrepreneurial
spirit that it's something it's in your
dna it's a part of who you are
it's not something you can just turn off
whatever you do you're going to do it
amazingly
and now what i'm particularly curious
about is hearing your your
entrepreneurial journey with the
companies that you've founded
and most specifically i i'd love to hear
the story of emerge then talking about
rooms and words what what's going on
there
what was the idea you partnered with
your co-founder and
and what happens
my amazing co-founder yeah so for me
because i didn't come from this world
and i think
more than just not coming from this
world i didn't know people
who had startups i didn't know people
who worked at startups
actually like looking back after i
started my startup i understood that i
did know people who worked in startups
or in tech generally but i didn't think
about them
this way they weren't you know in
founding teams etc
right it's like you probably can't
relate but a lot of times i'll have a
friend who has a baby and she'll say
nobody told me about this and it's not
true like the information is available
but you have to also be uh open
and uh kind of at the right stage for
you to absorb it
so for me it really wasn't
a life goal to start a technology
startup
i had my marketing agency i was very
happy it was also called rooms and words
it really evolved out of me
reaching out to magazine editors and
writing there about design from my blog
and then understanding that
one writing is very hard it takes a lot
of time
and it's not scalable and two
that there is a huge need especially for
lifestyle businesses that are very small
and it was pretty much the start of
e-commerce right between 2010
and 2016. uh and
they can do amazing wonderful things
abroad but they don't have the tools to
do it or even if they do they don't have
the time to do it they're busy leading
their
company manufacturing stuff etc
so that became a marketing agency for
lifestyle businesses
and one of those things and it's very
timely that we're speaking in march and
women's history
month was that most of my clients were
women
and many of them were kind of tech
dropouts
so they were in amazing roles in
technology
but then around having their kids they
felt like
they weren't fulfilled anymore or like
the
you know the hours or the um
organizational culture wasn't a good fit
for them anymore
and then they went and you know pursued
their passion which is great but
i kind of got stuck of like why did they
feel
like this industry and other industries
as well like
larger organization is kind of
um pushing them away after they've
worked there for years
and more and more i had conversations
with people mostly women but people in
general
about organizational culture and what
it's doing
to employees and at some point
i just became so i don't know if to say
passionate or just annoyed by it
and i said okay is there a difference to
do something about it
yeah i think it's a scale right
sometimes
being annoyed pushes you to being
passionate about something
so i just decided to do a survey
for women in the workplace exploring
this and and saying like maybe i'm not
right
right and part of the idea was i was
i just read uh cheryl sandberg's amazing
book lean in
where she explores all of those matters
and i said it's really important that we
have more and more
books and workshops and events it was
just the beginning of it now we have a
lot
uh it was in 2015 but what happens
in the day-to-day right when people are
coping and dealing with things
so i i wrote this 30 question survey
very very long do not recommend such
long surveys
uh but somehow despite the length
uh within one week 500 women from 56
different countries
answered the survey oh my god wow
many like tens of them sent me
messages telling me their stories and
asking me so where is this magic app
that we can download we'll make it all
better um
and i was just moved into action it made
no sense at all and i'll make like the
very long story a little bit shorter
because i know we only have
less than 20 minutes now but
it resulted in creating a platform for
organizations called emerge
which helped employees no matter their
gender or background because
fast forward we understood how big the
need is and how diverse the need is
to find mentoring and to find job
shadowing and really find connections
that could help them learn and connect
and create a sense of belonging
to their organizations and we worked we
were very lucky
first of all i was very lucky to be
joined by by my
co-founder and cto granite who is the
same person who built my
blog years before um
and we were very lucky to work with
amazing companies uh
facebook siemens license really
uh future oriented you know forward
thinking companies
that understood that the need wasn't
only
that of the employees but also that
organizations
need that they need their employees to
be fully motivated and invested
and to feel like they're heard because
that's when they're most
passionate that's when they're most
effective
and that's when they can actually
recognize their talents
uh so that was emerge uh which we
decided to shut down during covid so
almost a year ago
uh which has been an interesting journey
and full of lessons onto itself
so i i think that's that's exactly where
we should be heading that so you're
you're running this company you decide
to close and and
let's let's talk to me from the moment
you decide to close
what happens what what is your own
journey as an entrepreneur
at that moment so
i think for me the decision to shut down
was very like for for all of us right
the me my co-founder our team
our investors our clients which
found emerge more relevant
and more you know critical than ever
before once everybody went into remote
working and had even less of a sense of
connection so it was a really really
difficult
decision but also
we had a very different and hard path
of fundraising and it felt like it
wouldn't be fair
to anyone uh not to me and my co-founder
who were already very burnt
out we knew that with every you know
fundraise and every round and i think
this is something that is not spoken
about enough
um it takes a toll it takes toll on your
health it takes a toll on your
um on your soul on your spirits on your
family
um and it wasn't sustainable and at that
point we felt
that even if we were able to raise a
small amount of money to sustain us for
a few months
in covet it wouldn't be fair to the
investors
we felt like their money would only go
to close the company
and that was i felt like that was a real
ethical
question like i know people who would
have raised that money
and we decided not to and it wasn't an
easy thing you know
i think especially with our amazing
investors
they decided to invest in us even though
we were not
it wasn't a clear and obvious choice a
startup
which is one of the first hr tech
startups in israel
led by women led by
people who look differently who come
from different places and experience
so especially because of that uh it was
very difficult to have those
conversations even though we tried to be
transparent with them the entire way and
hopefully it didn't come at a surprise
to anyone
and they were just amazing so amazing
that one of my
investors actually offered me a job like
an hour after
i told her uh that we're going to close
and she said hey you're available i
don't want to miss you so it didn't pan
out but
it was like a real validation uh
the next step was i think at once
she's amazing and we did have 50 women
investors by the way which i think is
very different
wow in our industry and we were very
very proud about that
um the next step was i think
uh first of all relief being a ceo
is a big toll it's a big
way to carry and it's an amazing way to
carry and i felt
very very privileged to be in that
position
and hopefully uh sometime in the in the
future again
um but it's also a lot
so there was relief i was very relieved
that we also
um a few months before that uh
let some people go so they didn't have
to look for a job
during covid uh so it's kind of
you know very jewish relief and uh
and guilt mixed together
um and then yeah you know
and then the next the next step was
really kind of trying to understand who
i am
when you we started this conversation by
talking about being passionate about
your
hobbies right when you're a startup ceo
at least in my
experience and i think it can be
different and maybe it should be
different everything i did was emerge i
didn't you know breathe
oxygen that was furniture so
right it was it was really interesting
and not really easy to figure out
wait a minute who am i uh if i'm not
emerge
right and what is my value
also i never thought about myself as
someone who has a huge ego
but it does go into your head i think
especially
you know part of our difficulty was
being different
but it was also part of like we got a
lot of coverage and
articles and hey if i'm not this
groundbreaking
founder what is the value that i bring
to the world
and so it was um it still is
a really interesting journey of
exploring that
and as someone who authenticity is very
is very very important
to me uh i felt it was challenging to
not silence myself and to talk about it
and not to just let people think that
i'm still doing emerge so
it's it's interesting i think to myself
at least
i i can't imagine you know i think that
at the end
you know and knowing how to react you
know both externally and internally i
never
had the opportunity to to reach one of
these situations either for you know
the great accomplishments or for the
great failures and and and i'm
curious as to how i'll react personally
how i'll
you know react in front of others how
i'll you know think and what i'll be
thinking before i go to sleep and
and what kind of you know thoughts will
go through and emotions and
you know conversations like these uh
inspire me to to understand that it's
complicated and there is no answer
and i think at the end what i'm
gathering is that you're just very
intentional about what you do and you're
very thoughtful about what you do
and while you know thank you journey
here is very specific to you
what i'm while the journey is very
specific i you know i'm gathering that
at the end
you know the key to to knowing
some guiding is through being through
being intentional and to first
acknowledging that it's hard and
acknowledging that it's not
that it's not intuitive necessarily we
could be talking for hours more we
didn't even get a chance to talk about
the
the incredible company that you're
running now
and but we're gonna have to leave that
for another episode i 20 minutes just go
by way way too fast
but i do have the most important
question that i have to ask you
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
oh wow i thought about it but now i need
to remember
um i think three
i think the three uh words that i would
use and i'm probably
flattering myself are uh
curious uh authentic and
brave why not if nobody will say that
i'll say it
i love it thank you very very much
stay safe and stay healthy i look
forward to continue getting inspired by
the journey and thank you for taking the
time to meet with me i really appreciate
it
thank you so much for having me i really
really appreciate it
of course take care bye
[Music]
you